Hey okay you can hear record all right
so hello everyone my name is Aisha
bellow I walk for Cisco as in a small
team called global virtual engineering
and I walked as the virtual systems
engineer in the datacenter
virtualization practice and today I'm
going to talk about spying on my network
for a day so the networking world as I
like to call it I just started in like
ten months so I was trying to like look
for a way to combine my love all my
first love which is you know data
science and data analysis with you know
networking which is like a different
domain all together to start with do we
all get these kind of questions where
someone is like like my network is slow
I have no idea what's going on I mean
sometimes my phone is backing up through
an upload bandwidth which sometimes is
like 1/10 of the actual download
bandwidth or maybe my neighbor one is my
password now and there's big things that
I should be aware of or I mean it could
be like the line of the fibre to home
line you know it's bad oh maybe the NSA
is spying on me who knows right so well
god did you get the questions we don't
know what's going on our network and and
sometimes it helps to be curious to know
you know what's going on like how do I
know what's going on so I had a lot of
questions how do I know what's taking up
all my network bandwidth how how can I
tell what's going on in my network cuz
sometimes like where I come from in
Nigeria we don't have five-o to whom
what we do have is modem and you provide
your data so you buy like two gig of
data and you probably I'm like one day
I'm back home and all of a sudden is
finished but I'm like I'm very sure I
have not used up to 2 gigabits of data
so what's going on I mean if I can tell
what's taking on my network bandwidth I
mean I can detect if it's my neighbor or
maybe it's a man I'm not just aware of
the fact that my computer is meeting up
with a lot of grand retour data so in
trying to delete experience it's I
asking my question
ask myself questions along the way I'm
like okay so okay now I know what I want
to do so how do I capture my own detail
what's the best way to do this and
usually when you know how much data that
you capture or how much data that you
use you can basically plan so most of
you are like machine learning expert and
let's say for example you want to learn
about your your network you want to take
a snapshot over one week and you want to
learn and so you know it snap shot you
have like you have your behavioral
pattern the network is telling you what
your beaver pattern is and when you
diverge from that pattern you can set up
alarms and say okay this is a wet
website or this is a word market dress
like what's going on so basically around
planning so I know how much data I need
I can plan for the storage I can plan
that okay for every day I use 2 gigabits
of data and I want to learn about my
network in one week I should plan for
like 14 sorts of gigabits like in my
hard drive this is an example which you
know answer the question where would I
start right and so in this experiment I
was like ok I want to try and be you
know unbiased and I'm like ok when is
the best time for me to collect this
data she did when I'm at work she did we
went on my home because I have to
complete it anyway like I'm using one
for work and one for emitting one person
also when is the best time to actually
collect this data and now that I have is
how do I go about analyzing it and going
on a bit to the experimentation sets up
so this is basically what I use windows
yeah anyone excited for me and my Murata
home is the download speed is there and
the machine I use is the Lenovo and for
the experiment is where I shop I use
visualization to use Wireshark analyzed
and capture the network traffic and I
use bouquet to visualize the data using
jupiter ipython notebook and so I need
to give you all the warning if you're
going to do this if you are like me and
you share an apartment through other
people you should maybe access
right before trying to take judge
culture the Intel pockets low because I
have like two flatmates
and usually then let's so excited about
that no one ever is right but I feel
home you could like I knew you you like
you pay your dues like you have your
internet you're not sharing anyone you
can easily capture your data so before I
go into answering these questions let's
do some network 101 like we need honest
like it before you go into any data
project you want to have a bit of domain
knowledge about what it is it's going on
what it is really cannot I'm the IP
packet so I'm joking like maybe I'll go
through a lot of distance but go on to
what I think is very important for like
the duration of the talk I think the
first one is the version and you would
say that there now we have were moving
from that point where IP addresses like
you know then when the IP the IP version
4 came out no one knew how the
Internet's will boom like no one knew
how nowadays we'll have our mobile
devices and the only IP addresses so
we've moved on to the version 6 but this
part of the IP packet tells you tells
you what version of what version of the
IP you using and the type of service so
more than just collecting your data that
the idea is that when you're quick and
do analysis you can make informed
decisions you can learn something I can
make informed decisions and usually
they're different types of pockets there
is me on my Google hangout saying hello
buddy and the other guy on the other end
of the line is receiving the message but
then again the way that my data package
should be treated shouldn't be the same
where my voice packet is treated because
voice is very sensitive right so you use
they shouldn't be like a time log from
when it leaves when you say hello to
when the other person receives it so
there is like sensitivity and at
different ways you can handle your
pockets and those those kind of ways I
am forced by using this
just this part of the heads our total
length is basically the entire size of
your pocket so this is not this is not
just the Heather's is also is also
included like what's the data the size
of the data but now there is a limit
because for every hello you send it's
probably broken down into ten different
packets and it's rotted like all the
different routers in the internet to get
to where you are wherever you are going
little fragment offset which says okay I
have ten different pockets I'll probably
take different routes to the same
destination right so how do I assemble
them back together and this rebel offset
tells you it's the [ __ ] one or two or
three and that way it assembles them and
guesses the destination time to live is
a way so that if I say I want to send a
shot below an email and I mission I and
in email address and for some reason
it's wrong right but you've already sent
that message so time to leave is a way
to ensure that you know if your pocket
has the time to live reduces and gets to
zero it devout had knows to discard the
packet so that it doesn't keep going
around net or trying to look for a
destination that doesn't exist and now
the concept of addressing is if you want
to send me a package and I live in
Prague currently you probably know my
address as number 5 real Avenue but
that's my IP address right how do you
get access to me ok I stay in flat for
it has my MAC address but how do you get
to me I sure I'm sure my I have
flatmates so how do you get to me you
need to know or sometimes you know my
room so the network is like that you
need to know exactly not just your MAC
address not just your device but I need
to know the party needs to know which
application specifically so that when I
send my message from Google hangout
obviously cannot go to Skype like it
like there is a phone number and so
that's the whole concept of addressing
and moving on just going on to say
usually there's a stack and as data
moves down the stack there's an
encapsulation that go
that with the other information and as I
move moves up to get to you it's the
encapsulated the others are stripped or
want to read guess tree and get the
specific application so let's just say
that your packet is a mixture of your
actual data the transport information
your head that information and a lot of
other things to make it I guess the
destination so enough said let's get to
the interesting part right so how much
data do i generate an ability on a daily
basis so that I can plan like I want to
take your father I wanna I want to have
an idea over a period of time how much I
call that so that I can plan ahead for
in terms of capacity because it's a
problem but there are many different
ways to solve them so I have two laptops
I have two computers rather I my work
and I spend nine hours of my day on my
work computer and maybe the rest I'm
already tired two hours I do a couple of
meals and I go to bed so how much data
to actually generates on a daily basis
now the experiment with me analyzing my
personal computer traffic not
necessarily my work data but I wanted to
have an idea of how much data I was
using any day and this is an example but
this is a typical day way of nothing
spectacular I was happy you know I
wasn't having video calls or you know
Dindo this other thing so this was one
of those days in the week where
everything explains a slow nothing major
so yes from from there you can plan for
example in retrospect how much data do I
consume and you can plan like okay I
want to do I want to learn about my the
behavior of the characteristics of my
network over a couple of of weeks or
month and you can plan effectively and
so my pockets flow for a day so this was
like the entire day and I was just
trying to see okay what's going on like
where the spikes in the net in in my
network at all times am I using the most
bandwidth but
interesting to know is that for every
second you're not necessarily pocket or
not necessarily leaving your computer
every second in a second you might
really like your computer or your
machine can release up to like some 30
to 50 different packets from different
angles different sources even services
you are now aware so I mean as a
snapshot this is more like an
aggregation of the time on a per second
level and seen in a second which could
be as many as 20 different packets like
how much bandwidth was conceived at that
point in time and you can you can make
some assumptions and say oh okay
at this point it's um you know the small
that said the small at that low point
there's some there's some someone
looking for an IP address someone just
came home or there are like and there's
an address resolution that wants to born
you know so many different things that
you could you could infer from this but
the power is not the pause more
individualization it's how that you can
you can have all of this information and
you can visualize it just by visualizing
it you can make some you can make some
inference and you can you know make
decisions at the end of the day so I'm
zooming in into the first 300 seconds
which was like an aggregate so how much
bytes was I consuming on tests know what
exactly was going on like there is an
average right so maybe at this point of
five where is the web aggregate is 5,000
maybe I was watching a YouTube video or
something but where is this why is there
just like hit spike all of a sudden and
that happens at one moment and sometimes
you can even from a security standpoint
if you you don't know what happens when
you know your computer right so even
without you doing anything there so
there's so much information such a
device
gives out it's always like sending
information services that you are not
even aware so from a security angle you
can
make an analysis based on legacy on the
visualization and say ok if something of
this nature happens send me an alarm
then maybe you could go on and
investigate that little point so I just
wanted to show here what the what the
pockets capture is like there's so much
information so apart from having like
the source of the destination your
addresses their uses you can see like so
this is why I shop because I didn't
mention I didn't mention that before so
you can see how much bytes you're
consuming obviously this is not this is
not a lot of viruses ok there's an
application data then ok probably and
acknowledgements is going on what I
think I wanted to emphasize here at this
point is that there's so much going on
there is an there's an address
resolution going on there is TCP
acknowledgments going on but then there
is like when you drill down into the
pocket you'd know what it is
specifically like if you use like the
the I mean the IRS day you go in you'd
see a lot more information but I mean
what I wanted to do was like really how
much of my bandwidth am i using for what
specific purpose so I did like some sort
of visualization to see what this was so
I mean it might not be like a it's not
API it's it's not more like majority of
your boundaries will probbably go to
youtube videos or it so it will go to
some other kind of videos but is using
statistics you can tell what's going on
and even in UDP there's so many things I
use GDP so it's not only videos you can
see all the changes in UDP like the
quickly dip in tech and Internet
connections sometimes even your voice
buckets use UDP instead like because
they need to go fast they don't need the
extra baggage that comes with a TCP
packet and they just all you care about
the speed you don't care about where I
live at or not so different protocols
for different
Pappas's and so this is just like the
statistics of what and what specifically
was consuming what that's what like so
the entire entire culture is and this is
saying what percentage of the Capshaw is
doing is which protocol but there is a
lot of information that you can deduce
from here and you know I'm sitting there
trying to understand okay what is Creek
UDP internet connections what's going on
like what is this is just YouTube like
how much you TV I used to begin with
then then what happens
Veronica comes home hey I'm home I'm
like I know you're home like so from the
moment you're within serving as my
flatmates okay and the moment before she
tells me she's home I know I don't know
if you see that sometimes this could
even be a way to detect burglary like
what are the web weirdness going on like
before you get to I know you're home
because dhyryam signal
you know picks up on your device and
says okay this is normal
sign it can tell when my mom gets home
or my dad gets home or I can tell when
there is a very wait MAC address going
on and sometimes it's not just passing
by you can detect if somebody's passing
by I know how long they stayed in the
particular place within the area of your
signal as opposed to if they were really
in the house and who I'm not expecting
anyone and all of a sudden with Greiner
but this is just like oh I'm home I'm
like yeah I know you're home I knew
before you got go home I really knew you
at home and there's anyone know what
Google video comm is no YouTube I didn't
know that I was like oh so why does
youtube.com with Google video okay then
I went on but but the point is that so
this for example is a session it's a
session that there was a communication
that happens between my client and the
server and the session is basically from
the when I say hello I need something so
when the server replies
and from where those information is sent
when I get what I need up that
connection is terminated so this is this
is like a stream to say okay
437 MB what exactly was I getting from
YouTube I mean this is just an example
but there are many ways that you can
think about it and you can spin this
around who knows who this is Shanti
Shanti Shanti Shanti it's me it's me
three three remember to a nickname so
this is just saying you can get so much
information you can know the device you
can get information even when you get in
when you get a response from the server
if you're getting from like a website
you can get information about the
specific server that is serving you so
there's so much information that you can
get basically from analyzing your
Capshaw or your packet so in all is what
what's why should you care why should
you care about what goes on in your home
router many of us for example might be
developers and we do majority of our
work at home so I mean if if I'm going
to I have what critical applications
right I need to have my meetings I need
to have my calls how do I ensure that my
son or my daughter is not using this
boundary for video imaging or which
server either game video and no it's
video playing like games rest of you
guys that's what I call it right okay
okay so so there's so much motivation
that can go to why you should analyze
your network but one of it is there is a
lot of data we generates lots and lots
of data whether we whether we know it or
not there's a lot of things our
computers do without realizing it like
seriously there is even more data like
every micro milliseconds you're
generating lots and lots of packets and
it can give you on a broader scale we
can give you insight as to what's going
on for example I made the total capture
I go was like my personal capture for
that day was 354 there
about and that resulted to over four
hundred and four hundred and fifty four
thousand watts of packet capture don't
analyze just so just imagine like the
volume of information that you have and
this is what organizations use because
nowadays what most was seen malware why
not seen mouth got Donna did even OH
all you needed was a firewall and you
were protected now it's there's so many
ways you can get like malware from
emails to the websites that you visit in
to other things by analyzing the packets
you can tell because once you know the
flow of the packet you know how it you
go or what it should look like you can
tell when there's an anomaly which I
think the machine learning at this point
is what many people should use or can
use to know a lot about their network it
can be on police using machine learning
there are other ways that you can go
about solving this problem I went the
low level analysis way but there's so
many other ways that you can go about it
and you can use it you can be on police
you can you can detect if it's your
neighbor that has your password as a
word as a webmaster dress somewhere you
can you can detect if something like if
there's a service I shouldn't be sending
there's a word service going on and you
can drill down to see ok maybe this
might be someone already infiltrated my
system and send in information from my
computer to their several their command
and control center somewhere so why
would you want to automate the process
so I know the majority of the audience
are data Sciences or data engineers and
why should you care about automating the
process right it could be a process of
just visualizing your data and you know
hooking up a dashboard and you can
visualize what goes on how the traffic
flows what is what is what is important
traffic and what is not important
traffic you can set policies little
policies like you know what Facebook I'm
addicted I think I'm addicted to
Facebook
as an example and I can set that okay no
dis number this amount of bandwidth
should go to Facebook like 10 MB for
example but you can detect intrusions
for example you can learn so you can
learn over week understand your your
network behavioral characteristics get
those insights set policies our apply
the rules and you can relearn and keep
learning and it becomes really robust
because you can detect when something is
outside of the normal behavior you can
detect anomalies you can do this
differently so like I said before I went
like low-level capture looking at it
like you cannot capture looking at
streams of culture looking at what was
important was no important but you can
go different you can boldly a7 I only
want to see how much bandwidth each
application is consuming so in my base
Skype it might be a hangouts it might be
any other application I hope that you
know sends information but you can think
about this differently you can have a
Raspberry Pi and hook it up in the
middle to collect all that data and you
know send it to the cloud somewhere and
have this nice fancy dashboard showing
you visuals and you can set alarms so
there are many ways that you can go
around this and there are other
application there are the open-source
tools that you can use to analyze your
traffic like snot likes KP stuffy I'm
not sure how it's pronounced but
copyscape e you know you know what I
mean or Moloch because there are so many
ways that you can go about it and mine
was you know I get this culture i i i
filter the important information i want
from Wireshark and and export it as its
psv and i visualize it in bouquet but
there are frameworks that that that
specific for packet capture that maybe
the other ideas i have not even thought
about it you're probably already
thinking about also people can all like
you know if you like to hack we can hack
you can have your router firmware using
open wrt i've seen it i personally would
not because i really don't want to mess
with what i want when i go is I want
internet I don't
mess with our process right so up it
could be something interested in but
there are just many different ways they
can go about doing this which I want to
highlight so what did I learn about
myself after all of this that I am
addicted to this blog called Stella's
blog
I should probably reduce the number of
times and the number of time I spend on
the blog
note to self you know constantly
learning about ourselves every day it
for anyone else it could be Facebook it
could be treatable mine is the specific
blog I need to you know watch it and be
more productive or you know I'm using
windows and there's just so many
services I don't need that happens like
I don't want it and you're taking up my
bandwidth you can disable you can you
can know which of these services are
sending traffic and you can actively go
and disable the ones that you don't need
like I don't need to whether I put on my
computer I have my phone for that
there's so many ways um t they can
discover just as an example well I can
tell my mom gets home or when I have
visitors or when maybe just a bla bla
bla
Thank You Han questions yay no questions
okay really
I must have done a good job
I thank you for the talk would you mind
going over the example where you you can
see that someone got a home I think that
just went by quite fast I didn't okay
you mean you want me to go back I didn't
like explain how you could tell someone
got home um so it was so the the thing
is when you when you're within like a
place where you have the an RF signal
Wi-Fi your phone is genuine is on it
tries to connect so it's been a lot of
hello hello I'm here a man anyone I need
the an IP address hello hello so in my
case that's what happened and I knew she
was home because she was sending DHCP
requests and screaming I need an IP
address I need an IP address and we know
from the MAC address you can tell
specifically you know which device is
and you know she has a name in the
iPhone that you know and you can tell
from that basically by the broadcast of
pockets and saying I need like like a J
superior perfect also configure thank
you for your question
I'm just curious if you did or if you
thought about doing an experience where
you are using a software for instance
you're using your favorite idea to
develop code and you don't do anything
else and you just want to figure out
whether that software which might be
closed is sending stuff to someone that
you are not aware of it I think that
will be one interesting thing to explore
with all that what you set up that's
true but is that a question or a kind of
a suggestion all right great yes or not
yes yes okay yeah because I noticed one
thing that you discovered was that
service whether from Microsoft right
yeah there's so many services that are
just an example one of the main I
believe most of the software that we use
there yeah sending those stuff that we
are not even aware of that's true is
very true
thank you
hi are you worried about your neighbors
being able to tell when you're home or
not that's a very good question yes I'm
worried okay um yes I I would say I'm
worried but yeah I guess they could tell
you they had my password and you know
could do like a monitoring I mean I mean
maybe this would be an example put some
rules so that no one can do packet
capture and you open your router at home
thank you for that I should really go
home and do that hi thanks for the talk
and have you could you tell us a bit
about the the precautions you've taken
maybe in the past year or any new
practices any any advice based on this
yeah since you're worried about your
neighbors knowing about your life I well
I saw this project I did we be in a
space of one month so he wasn't like
like over like a long period of time but
the idea is that if I know um what
applications or if I know where the most
of my bandwidth goes I can mitigate
against how much time I spent there or
what people can do when I'm not looking
I'm sure I don't know if that answered
your question but uh did that answer
your question yeah okay